[Music]  our forests  are growing silent healthy forests are  much more than  trees they are living ecosystems and  home  to eighty percent of the world's known  terrestrial plants  and animals they provide a wide range of  benefits to people  the planet and the economy the eu forest  strategy will make sure  forest ecosystems are better protected  restored  and managed we have seen a huge global  movement of people  asking for more forest protection and  rightly so  too many forests are being degraded  destroyed or  exploited all over the planet we will  present  new legislation to avoid products  associated with  deforestation enter the eu market  our livelihoods and future depend on  them  you